[Music]
this is something I feel like I've
always wanted to try but I've never
found a studio to try that and like I
didn't know the safe ways to really go
about trying all these moves but you see
it in the movies and you get to try it
out and I'm really excited to be a
little superhero today
[Music]
I started gymnastics when I was four
years old so I'd always been flipping
and jumping off of things and falling
off of things on purpose it just seemed
like a very natural progression so I
started choreographing fights for local
productions for stage and student films
and local films like that so it's always
been my passion I got a call one day to
train actors on a tiny little film
called The Matrix which I heard did okay
but I trained especially Laurence
Fishburne and a little bit of Keanu and
kerri-anne and that's when I really
started integrating the Chinese style of
wire work with the martial arts that I
was already doing and that's been my
specialty ever since
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh like nice outing these math I know
[Music]
yeah one more time
[Music]
it's a lot of fun I'm ready to twirl
ready to flip ready to kick somebody in
the face professional stunt performers
come to me for either brush-up of their
training or to learn new skills but also
I've worked with actors who don't have a
lot of background but more and more
actors are being called upon to do some
of their own stunts a lot of their own
fights some of their own wire work
because the movie business has morphed
into much more action when I first came
I was a little intimidated but I was
more excited
I definitely feel more comfortable in
the harness now and it's a little weird
positioning your body and feeling your
weight out on the wires because each
harness is different
I'm just taking acting classes and stunt
classes and trying to learn as much as I
can so that I can be my best
[Music]
we're breaking actually through a real
drywall wall that we've built here which
is exactly what we would do on a real
movie set they've seen builders would
build the wall for us and we would score
it in the right ways so that it breaks
more easily and then we put those stunt
performers through it with the wires
I really get nervous I just get excited
I might get pumped up and then like
after it's done
[Music]